CHARGES PLEASE CALL IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND. WHAT WERE
ALL SET TO START THERE IS A
QUORUM. MISTER SECRETARY COULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL. SURE. ALL
RIGHT. TO ESTABLISH. A QUORUM
QUIRK HERE QUIRK ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AS HE RK CAN HEAR.
FLORA FLORA. CRISTINA HOLDEN
ALL THAN HERE. MATHIS NOT THIS
YEAR I SU CHI. OBERNOLTE HERE
OBERNOLTE HERE WE HAVE A CAR
GREAT RIGHT. YEAH STANDARD
PROCEDURES THAT WERE WORKING ON.
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE HEARING. TO
THE CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
WATER YOU'RE PRACTICING.
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HEARING TO
HEAR FOR AND THROW THE CAMP
BUILD SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH. HOLDEN HEARING IN PERSON
WE ALSO REQUIRED THAT MATH THE
ONE. AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING TO
BE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASK YOU CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TODAY. BUT TODAY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH TWO WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMUM. IN A
STAFF AND LOCAL NUMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACE IN
THERE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
FIFTEEN PROTOCOLS. THE REPUBLIC
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
HERE IN THE ROOM IF ANY LEVEL
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFIED- PLEASE RAISE
YOUR AND THEN I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING NO
TRYING TO RECEIVE. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING CAPITAL
INCLUDING. LIMITING ELEVATORS
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME WITNESSES
MAKING USE OF ONE OF OUR
WITNESSES VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS. WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE
IN THE CAPITAL AS WELL AS
REMOTE TESTIMONY SITES. LOCATED
ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS AND
OTHER LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO LASSEN QUESTION.
WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
CHAIR TESTIFIED A BILL. COLIN
NUMBER FOUR. IN. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINETEEN. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOURTEEN. ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE ENDS
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOUR CALL. PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON.
IS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS. ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL.
IF YOU WERE CALLING IN WE'VE
PLANTED YEAH. IF YOU WERE
CALLING AND PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS
INCLUDES MUTINEER LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICE.
TO REDUCE THE SENATE DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDED
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL. YOU REMAIN ON THE LIVE
LINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU COULD CALL
THE COMMUNITY AT. NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE SIX
FIVE. AND OUR STAFF WILL BE
THERE TRY TO TRY TO HELP. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
FOR THE POSITION BLESSED BETTER
PARTIAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BILLION
WITNESSES WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL OF RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH REAL CONCERNS WE
ALL FACE. I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA.
WHO IS FILLING IN FOR THE
REPUBLICAN VACANCY FOR THIS
HEARING WELCOME HE AS YOU KNOW
SEND YOUR- MEN AND MELISSA
MELENDEZ. WAS ELECTED TO THE
SENATE CONGRATULATIONS MELISSA.
ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE TO MAINTAIN PROPER
MASK USAGE AT ALL TIMES. PLEASE
DO NOT REMOVE OUR LOW YOUR MASK
ON SPEAKING WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PROMPT. COOPERATION YOU WILL
HEAR FOR BILLS TODAY. ONE IS
PRICED FOR CONSENT. TESTIMONY
IS LIMITED TO FOUR MINUTES EACH
ONFOR EACH SIDE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES PLEASE BRIEFLY STATE
YOUR NAME POSITIONAL
AFFILIATION WITH ALL THE WAY.
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT WE NOW
HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR COULD
I GET A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH IS SB. ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX. RIGHT AND THE MOTION
WILL BE GIVEN PASSED IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE PROCESS
CALENDAR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS COMPRISED
OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
ARCHULETA WITH THE MOTION DO
PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. QUIRK I QUIRK AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI THERE CAN
PARA QUE HAN HI. FOUR FIVE
FLORA I. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I MATHIS MATHIS I
MURATSUCHI. OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
I. ALL. ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO HEAR SB SIX BY SENATOR
DOLE ALSO. POOR POOR FIVE
QUARTERLY REPORT FIRST ONE IS
START OFF BY THANKING SENATOR
RAWSON FOR A HARD WORK ON THIS
TOPIC. SCIENCE IS CLEAR THAT
EXPOSURE TO FOR HER FIVE OTHER.
WITH DAN- FAST A PESTICIDES CAN
HAVE SIGNIFICANT MEN WITH
NEGATIVE IMPACTS. ESPECIALLY
FOR CHILDREN AND DEVELOPING
FETUSES. WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
KEEPING THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC IN
THE SPOTLIGHT. OKAY SENATOR YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING- AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRPERSON QUIRK AND
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE COMMITTEE
OF FOR YOUR TIME AND-
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL SB EIGHTY SIX WILL REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. TO SUBMIT QUARTERLY
REPORTS THAT PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON GRANULAR
CHLORPYRIFOS USE TO LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES AND THE OFFICE OF
THE SURGEON GENERAL. CALIFORNIA
HAS A CRITICAL TO US IN AND SHE
THAT FARMER. THE FACT IS ARE
PUT. BRISTOL BACK OF EXPOSURE
TO HARMFUL PESTICIDES CLEAR
PURIFIES IS ACUTELY TOXIC AND
ASSOCIATED WITH NEAR
DEVELOPMENTAL HARMON CHILDREN.
BRING CAN BE EXPOSED TO
CHLORPYRIFOS WHEN THEIR PARENTS
OR SIBLINGS BRING THE PESTICIDE
INTO THE HOME ON THEIR SKIN
CLOTHING AND SHOES CHILDREN
EXPERIENCE GREATER EXPOSURE TO
CHLORPYRIFOS AND OTHER
PESTICIDES. BECAUSE RELATIVE TO
ADULTS THEY EAT DRINK AND
BREATHE MORE IN PROPORTION TO
THEIR BODY WEIGHT. MIDDLE AND
EARLY LIFE EXPOSURE TO
CHLORPYRIFOS IS ASSOCIATED WITH
ELEVATED RISKS A REDUCED IQ
LOSS OF WORKING MEMORY DELAYS
AND MOTOR DEVELOPMENT ATTENTION
DEFICIT DISORDERS AND
STRUCTURAL CHANGES IN THE BRAIN.
OCTOBER NINTH TWENTY NINE
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION ANNOUNCED
THAT IT HAD REACHED A LEGAL
SETTLEMENT WITH CHLORPYRIFOS
REGISTRANTS WERE BY. SALES OF
CERTAIN CHLORPYRIFOS PRODUCTS
WOULD END BY FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY THE DEPARTMENT CLARIFIED
THAT PRODUCTS THAT APPLY FOR
PEER FUSS AND ITS GRANULAR FORM
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO REMAIN ON
THE MARKET. THE P. R. AND THE
DEEP CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE CREATED A
CLEAR PAYER FALSE ALTERNATIVES
WORKGROUP TO IDENTIFY EVALUATE
AND RECOMMEND TURNED IT MATTER
SALUTE. IN THERE JUST A CLIPPER
A SEARCH CORPORATE FOST THANKS
THE DPRK KNOWLEDGE THAT IT ONLY
CONSIDERED SPRAY DRIFT DIETARY
EXT JUST CLICK. DPR DID NOT
EVALUATE THE WAYS THE GRANULAR
CHLORPYRIFOS CAN HARM WORK. ON
THE OTHER IN TWENTY AND IT'S
TWENTY SIXTEEN ASSESSMENT THE
UNITED STATES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY CONSIDERED
OVER SEVENTY USES OF GRAND
CHLORPYRIFOS. THAT FEDERAL
AGENCY CONCLUDED THAT ALL OF
THESE USES PRESENT RISKS OF
CONCERN TO FARMWORKERS EVEN
WHEN PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT IS WORN. NOW I WOULD
LIKE TO DISCUSS DEEP YARDS
CURRENT REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT SB
EIGHTY SIX FITS WITHIN DPR IS
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
REPORTING PESTICIDE USE. THE
DPR IS REQUIRED TO BE PART
ANNUAL REPORTS OF PESTICIDE USE
AND QUARTERLY REPORTS A
RESTRICTED. SIDE YOU. THE MOST
RECENT ANNUAL REPORT THAT WE
CAN ACCESS IS THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE THE PUBLIC NEEDS
TO KNOW THE INFORMATION THAT IS
AVAILABLE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY TEN REPORTS. IN
TERMS OF RESTRICTED PESTICIDE
SUCH AS GRANULAR CHLORPYRIFOS
ALL COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT RESTRICTED PESTICIDE USE
REPORTS TO THE DPR. THE COUNTY
AGRICULTURE COMMISSIONERS ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THESE
REPORTS MONTHLY. THEN THE DPR
DIRECTOR IS REQUIRED TO
SUMMARIZE THE DATA ON THE TYPE
OF MATERIAL AN AMOUNT ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS THESE SUMMARIES
SHALL BE MADE AVAILABLE. BUT
THE DPR DIRECTOR HAS THE
DISCRETION WHETHER OR NOT THE
PUBLISH OR DISTRIBUTE THE
SUMMARIES FOR THE MORE EVEN THE
CHLORPYRIFOS ALTERNATIVES
WORKGROUP. WE COMMEND BOARDING
FOSS USE AND SHARE THIS
INFORMATION WITH THE PUBLIC SB
EIGHTY SIX FOLLOWS THAT
RECOMMEND. BEING OF CHANGE. AND
THAT'S NOT AVAILABLE ON A
REPORTS. SB EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES
A DEEP YARD TO PROVIDE CORD
REPORT AND THEN SUBMIT IT IS
TWO SIX IS COMMITTEE INCLUDED
BECAUSE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL.
I'M THE BILL GIVES THE PR SIXTY
DAYS. WE NEED GREATER
TRANSPARENCY OVER THE USE OF
GRANULAR CHLORPYRIFOS THIS
INFORMATION MUST BE ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
LIKE FARMWORKERS ALL WE WANT IS
TO TRACK THE USE A GRANULAR
USES OUR CORE PEER FOSS AND
IT'S HEALTH IMPACTS ON
FARMWORKERS. FINALLY I JUST
WANT TO END WITH THE WORDS OF
SAYS OUR JOB IS THE CO FOUNDER
OF THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
UNION AFTER HIS LAST
UNCONDITIONAL WATER ONLY FAST.
IF GROWERS ARE CHEMICAL
COMPANIES CAN SHOW THAT
STANDARDS PROTECTING PEOPLE
WILL COST MORE THAN THEY
BENEFIT. THEY CAN GET OFF THE
HOOK. UNDER COST BENEFIT
STANDARDS ACOSTA PESTICIDE
SAFETY ARE QUANTIFIABLE LIKE
THE MONEY CHEMICAL COMPANIES
INVEST IN PRODUCING PESTICIDES
OR IN THE STOCK OF TOXICS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MANUFACTURED.
PROPS GROUPS CLASS BE
ENDANGERED IF SOME PESTICIDES
ARE BOUND. THE BENEFITS OF
PESTICIDE PROTECTION ESPECIALLY
LONG TERM CHRONIC THREATS TO
FARMWORKERS AND CONSUMERS ARE
IMPOSSIBLE TO EXPRESS IN
DOLLARS AND CENTS THEY ARE
OFTEN CONTAINED AT BEST IN
VAGUE STUDIES THANKS TO THE
GROWERS AND CHEMICAL COMPANIES
ARE RESISTED TESTING FOR HELP
TO FIX. SO THEY DON'T BàN THE
WORST OF THESE POISONS BECAUSE
SOME FORMER FOR MY GIVE BIRTH
TO A DEFORMED CHILD SO THEY
DON'T BAN IN- THEY DON'T
IMPERIL MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PROFITS TODAY BECAUSE SOME DAYS
SOME CONSUMER MIGHT GET CANCER.
SO THEY ALLOW ALL OF US WHO
PLACE OUR FAITH AND THE SAFETY
OF THE FOOD CHAIN TO CONSUME
GRAPES AND OTHER PRODUCE WHICH
CONTAIN RESIDUES FROM
PESTICIDES CARD K. SIR AND
BIRTH DEFECTS. SO WE ACCEPT
DECADES OF ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UPON THE
LAND. I'M SORRY I'M SORRY. THE
GROWERS CHEMICAL COMPANIES AND
OTHERS SAY THESE ARE ACCEPTABLE
LEVELS OF EXPOSURE BUT
ACCEPTABLE TO HOME ACCEPTABLE
TO FARMWORKERS AND THEIR SONS
AND DAUGHTERS WHO HAVE KNOWN
TRAGEDY FROM PESTICIDES THERE
IS NO ACCEPTABLE LEVEL EXPOSURE
TO ANY CHEMICAL THAT CAUSES
CANCER. THERE CAN BE NO
TOLERATION OF ANY TOXIC THE
CAUSES MISCARRIAGES STILLBIRTHS
AND DEFORMED BABIES. RISK IS
ASSOCIATED WITH ANY LEVEL OF
EXPOSURE AND ANY LEVEL OF
EXPOSURE IS TOO MUCH. ISN'T
THAT THE STANDARD PROTECTION
YOU WOULD ASK FOR YOUR FAMILY
AND YOUR CHILDREN. ISN'T THAT
THE STANDARD OF PROTECTION YOU
WOULD BE BANNED FOR YOURSELF.
SO WHY DO WE ALLOW FARMWORKERS
TO CARRY THE BURDEN OF
PESTICIDES ON THEIR SHOULDERS.
HE ENDURED A THIRTY SIX DAY
FAST TO PROTEST THE USE OF
PESTICIDES. MY WITNESSES TODAY
WILL BE NICOLE CHAVEZ BENEATH
THAT UNITED FARM WORKERS. TYLER
SMITH FROM EARTH JUSTICE AND I
WILL HAVE AVAILABLE BARBON CHAN
FROM EARTH JUST AS WHO WILL
HELP ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SENATOR. RIGHT BOB
MARLEY PLEASE PUT ON THE LINE
NICO CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS. YOU ARE
MISTER CHAVEZ YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. MORNING
MAKE A CHAVEZ I'LL BE AFTER
UNITED FARMWORKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTY SIX. DOCTOR CAN
YOU THE TERM THING UP. WHEN HE
SPOKE ABOUT EXPORTING COURT
PEOPLE HEALTH AND LIVES MONEY.
AND THE CLIENT NAME A LOOK THE-
I'M WORKERS ON THE FRONTLINE OF
EXPOSURE TO THE BRAIN DAMAGING
CHEMICAL QUICKER BOX. AND WHAT
TO A GOVERNESS ANNOUNCED THE
START OF THE CANCELLATION
PROCEEDING OR BAN ON QUICKER
PLUS. THE DOCTOR CHILL BUT THE
GOVERNOR THAT'S PARTLY. DEAL
WITH THE CHEMICAL INDUSTRY.
ALLOWED THE CONTINUED USE OF
THE BRAIN DAMAGING CHEMICAL A
GRANULAR FORM. THE DOCTOR COULD
CARRY KAREN ROSS OF THE
RECOMMENDED PRODUCTS THAT FROM
CANCELLATION. THE GOVERNOR'S
LEUPOLD DANGEROUS. SECRETARY'S
WANT. THANK YOU MEDICAL EXPERTS
WITHOUT THE COUNTRY HAVE
STUDIED THE BRAIN DAMAGE I'M A
CO WROTE RIGHT DECADE IN ALL
ITS FORMS. THEY CONCLUDE THAT
NOTE STATE FORM AND NO SAKE
LEVEL A QUICKER PARKS USE IT
THIS. AT THE EIGHTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE THE GOVERNOR.
SECRETARY'S ADMINISTRATION THE
LEAD. AND THE PUBLIC. WITH THE
USER'S DATA FOR THE DANGERS OF
DAMAGING FORM OF QUICKER BOX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
TRAVEL. I JUST WANT TO MENTION
FOR THOSE WHO ARE MAY NOT BE AS
FAMILIAR WITH THIS TOPIC. AT
WHAT THE GOVERNOR DID WAS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE DID
WAS TO. STOP ALL USES OF OUR
POOR EXCEPT IN THE GRANULAR
FORM AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
REPORT IS A BALL. PHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE PUT ON THE
LINE TYLER SMASHED ON BEHALF
VERY STRESSFUL MISTER SMITH YOU
MAY BE FULL WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN PILOT MET ON
BUYING IT DURING THE DAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR- A LARGE IF NOT
ENVIRONMENTAL LOT LOOKING IN
THE COUNTRY. ROUTE JOIN WITH
THE UNITED WORKERS AND THE
AMERICAN ACCOUNT OF PEDIATRICS
CAL. THE CODE BONTA BUT THAT
THAT. THERE ARE CLEAR AND CAN
EVIDENCE THAT EXPOSURE TO
CORPORATE BOUGHT IN THE WOMB
AND HARM CHILDREN BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT. THE END OF DIRTY
DOG YOU TO HUMAN AND ANIMAL
STUDIES CONDUCTED OVER THE PAST
THREE DECADES AND PUBLISHED IN
LEADING SCIENTIFIC JOURNAL. ALL
THE DEPARTMENT THE BOTTOM. HAVE
AMPLE THE REGISTRATION BUT
NEARLY ALL CUT BY PRODUCT BUT
BECAME POPULAR POP THANK YOU.
USE A GRANULAR QUICKER ARAFAT.
BOB WHAT IN A FAST. YET OUT THE
VALUE WAITED DOESN'T GIVE YOU
TO THE GRANULAR CORPORATE
FOUGHT IN THE DEPARTMENT THAT
ALL OF THEM RESULT IN UNPAID
LEVEL BURGER CO WORKER EVEN
WHEN DIRECT AND BUMP APPETITE
LABEL BUT POLICY AND MAC MORE
PERSONAL. PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
IS MARK. AND SENATOR ALL THE
MENTAL ON LIKE YOU AT THE- DPR
DIDN'T. EVALUATE GRANULAR
QUICKER FOUGHT IN THE PARK. AIR
CONTAMINANT REVALUATION
BLEEDING BUT THAT YOU'RE- CPR
THEREFORE DID NOT DETERMINE THE
GRANULAR CORPORATE BOUGHT. A
FARM WORKER. WE DO NEED TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT HOW GRANULAR QUICKER
FOUGHT YOU CAN CALIFORNIA YEAH
THERE'S A MULTI YEAR DELAY
BETWEEN WHEN A PATH WITHOUT
ISSUES AND ONE COMPLETE
INFORMATION ON THAT YOU MADE
AVAIL. UNDER THE CURRENT THAT
THEM WE MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT HOW
GREAT YOUR WORK WITH THEIR
ABOUT BEING USED THAT FOLLOWING
THE BAN ON OTHER FORMULATION OF
TWENTY TWENTY CORRECT. THAT THE
LIGHT. ON A- GIVEN THE KNOWN
RECORD THE PREGNANT WOMEN
CHILDREN. AT THE EIGHTY PICKED
CLICK RIGHT COLLECTION DECEMBER
OF TIMELY AND- ON THE GRAND LOT
QUICKER OFTEN CALIFORNIA WOULD
HELP THIRD AT THE LETTER. HAS
THE IMPRIMATUR IN THE ATTACK
ALL OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. I
ARE THE PORK AND RETIREMENT
WITH DAUGHTER BUT THE NOW READ
NAME. OF A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTING THE
LEGISLATION THAT COULD NOT BE
WITH US TODAY. AS I MENTIONED
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA WITH THE
COKE BUNKER ALL BOOKED
ACCORDING TO WHAT THE PLATE
AND- THE AND ARE. YOU FORTY
THIRTY ASIAN.BUT THE CREATION
OF REGIONAL BAKER AGENCIES.
CALIFORNIA CODE FOR A LINE.
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. THE MATRIX.
THE DARK ENERGY OR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
FRIENDS OF THE LA RIVER. UNLOCK
THE BOX. BILL PORT STORY ALL.
LA WATERKEEPER BECAUSE THE
COUPLE PRODUCTIVE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. THEY'RE
LIKE THE ERA. NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL A QUORUM A
BEAUTIFUL. THE BILL ALSO
RESPONSIBILITY ERIC BUT
CALIFORNIA URBAN TWENTY. LET
THE TERM MOVE THE BILL
ALL MOVE- TITLES AND ALL THE
WORLD- I'M SORRY I DIDN'T THE
MICROPHONE MOVE BY MR ARAMBULA
SECOND BY MISTER MURATSUCHI.
ALL RIGHT. ALL MORAL I THINK
THE INFO HOME FROM BELOW- FIVE
AND YEAH. FORMAL. ONE MORE. ONE
TO TOOLS AND FOR THE PEOPLE
YEAH FOR THE RECORD ALL RIGHT.
YEAH.
ALL MY MICROSOFT. OKAY DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY SIX OF THE
PHONE LINE. LATER THAT COULD
YOU PUT THEM ON THE LINE.
MODERATOR. YES I AM HERO WHO
ARE WE LOOKING FOR. IN SUPPORT
OF SB A. B. C. OKAY PLAYED.
PERFECT LEADING GERMAN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FOR
WILL COME THE LINE THIRD SEVEN.
ONE MOMENT AND I'LL OPEN YOUR
LINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO HEAD THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING REBEKAH MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM AND PESTICIDE
ACTION SUPPORT OUR PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK NORTH AMERICA
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE. DO IT ONE MORE ITS
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LEAVE THE LEAK BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. AT THIS
TIME. NOW WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
OPPOSITION TESTIFIED IN THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE WHERE.
WARRANT NO ONE HUNDRED ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL ORDER EVER
CULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING WESTERN PLAN HOW THIS
IS. HELLO ZIP MUTUAL WE ARE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LEARNING NO AND HE TO COME HAVE
A WESTERN PLAN HEALTH
ASSOCIATION CAL CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA'S AT CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HAS CONTROL
ADVISORS AS WELL AS SEVERAL
OTHER AG ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION SB EIGHTY SIX- WHAT
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT IS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE FINDINGS OF THIS BILL IT
DOESN'T PAINT THE WHOLE PICTURE
OF WHAT WE DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR THE STUDIES THAT
HAVE GONE INTO NOT JUST
GRANULAR CORPORATE FOSS BUT ALL
PESTICIDES HERE IN THE STATE-
PESTICIDES CARRY RISKS WE'RE
NOT. GOING TO GET AROUND THAT
POINT IT'S A PESTICIDE BUT WHAT
WE DO HAVE IS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS SAID REGULATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DOES EXTENSIVE
STUDIES ON ALL PESTICIDES AND
ONE FOR PURE FARCE THAT MEANS
AERIAL SPRAYS GRANULAR ALL
FORMS OF THEM THEY AREN'T
LEAVING ANYTHING OUT- THERE'S
ACTUALLY A MEMO DATED AUGUST
TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FROM THE PART SIDE OF ELATION
TO THE FOR DEPARTMENT. OF
TALKING ABOUT THE STUDY TO AND
WHY THEY DID IT JUST TO THE
CANCELLATION PROCESS ON BECAUSE
OF DRAFTING DIETARY CONCERNS.
NOT I'M- BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE.
EVIDENCE THAT IT POSES THE SAME
CONCERNS SO THERE WERE STUDIES
DONE ON THAT. FURTHER WE HAVE
EXTENSIVE PROGRAMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH DPR CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
SPECIFICALLY MAKE SURE THAT ANY
PESTICIDE IS NOT ENTERING OUR
WATER SYSTEM. OR OUR FOOD
SYSTEM AND CAUSING RESIDUE-
THERE HAVE BEEN NO ILLNESSES OR
INJURIES REPORTED IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN IT COMES TO
GRANULAR CHLORPYRIFOS. THERE'S
ALSO BEEN EXTENSIVE STUDIES
DONE ON IT AND THE FINDINGS ON
ACCOUNT FOR THIS THEY TALK
ABOUT. ALL USES A POOR PAIR FOR
US THEY TALK ABOUT IT BEING
BROUGHT HOME- AND EXPOSED TO
SIBLINGS AND OTHERS. I WILL
TELL YOU IT'S A VERY
RESTRICTIVE PESTICIDE RUNNING
PARKER FOSS IS ONLY ALLOWED TO
BE USED IN VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES MOSTLY ON. JUST
SPECIFIC CROPS THAT HAVE NO
ALTERNATIVES FOR CERTAIN PASS.
ANYONE WHO APPLIES IT FIRST HAS
TO GET A LICENSE IN ORDER TO
FIGHT THEY HAVE TO WEAR
PROTECTIVE GEAR. AND THEN THERE
ARE PERIODS WHERE NO ONE IS
ALLOWED TO ENTER AN ORCHARD
FIELD. IN AFTER THAT
APPLICATION. TO ENSURE THAT
NOTHING IS BEING TRACKED OFF
THE FIELD AND INTERFERING. WITH
CITIZENS OR THE ENVIRONMENT-
WORKING SIR. CONTINUOUS YOUR
MATH WE WILL GET MY TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ALL SAY THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSING SOMETHING
THAT- LEAVES OUT WHAT THE
AMAZING WORK WE'RE DOING HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE ARE
SPECIALLY OPPOSE. ALSO IN THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
WE HAVE TAYLOR. RUSSIAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TAYLOR
OCEAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU WE'D ECHO THE COMMENTS I
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE AN AD THAT
THIS BILL- INCREASES THE
WORKLOAD ON ALREADY
OVERBURDENED AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION. AT THAT WILL HAVE
POLICY AND FISCAL IMPLICATIONS
INCREASING THE FREQUENCY OF
REPORTING TO A QUARTERLY BASIS
I WILL LEAD TO THE PUBLICATION
OF POTENTIALLY INVALID REPORTS
EVERY COUNTY AND THE DEPARTMENT
UNDERTAKEN EXHAUSTIVE PROCESS
TO ENSURE THAT THE DATA IN THE
REPORTS ARE ACCURATE BEFORE
THEIR PUBLICIZED. SHOULD THIS
PROCESS BE DONE IN HASTE IN
ORDER TO MEET THIS DEADLINE AND
MISTAKES ARE MADE IT'S
CERTAINLY THREATENS THE
TRUTHFULNESS OF THAT DATA WHICH
DOESN'T SERVE THE BROADER
PUBLIC INTEREST IF ERRORS ARE
FOUND AND JUSTIN'S ARE MADE
PERIODICALLY WE'LL BE SEEING
MULTIPLE ADDENDUMS TO EACH
QUARTERLY REPORT. THAT ILL
MAKE BEING ABLETO
CHRONOLOGICALLY ASSESS THE
AMOUNT OF USE MORE AND MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ACHIEVE- IT ALSO WOULD
REPRESENTATIVES AT SEGREGATION
OF ONE ACTIVE INGREDIENT TO
QUARTERLY REPORTING BASIS-
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN ALL
OTHER. REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AT THE WORK DONE BY AG
COMMISSIONERS AND DPR IS NOT A
CHEAP TASK- DEBEERS COST TO
ADMINISTER THIS DATA. MANAGE
THE DATABASE AND ASSIST THE
COUNTIES IN DATA ENTRY IS ABOUT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS NEARLY HALF
OF THIS GOES TO COUNTY AYE
COMMISSIONERS FOR THAT DATA
ENTRY ALONE. THESE ACTIVITIES
ARE NOT FUNDED BY THE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS OR BY COUNTY
FUNDS. RATHER THE WORK IS PAID
FOR BY FEES ON REGISTRATIONS
AND THE MILL SAYS MINT WHICH IS
THAT FEE ASSESSED ON. I'M ALL
PASS A SALES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
DEPARTMENT STRETCHES THESE
FUNDS TO ALSO COVER THE
REMAINDER OF THE ESSENTIAL
FUNCTIONS OF DPR LIKE
ENVIRONMENTAL MONITORING. RISK
ASSESSMENTS AND EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC AND APPLICATORS. ALL OF
WHICH HAVE INCREASED OVER TIME.
ADDING DVRS COMMIT AND
COMMISSIONERS REPORTING. TO THE
BILL WILL NOT ASSUREDLY DIRECT
FUNDING AND LEAVE OUT PRIME.
FUND ON. OR ON. WE THE- ON IN
FOR CHANCE. IN FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT IN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTANCE WE CAN'T IDENTIFY
INDISCERNIBLE PUBLIC BENEFIT
FROM THE BILL. THAT WOULD
RESULT IN MORE SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE FINE CON. THANK
YOU. THANK FOR ALL. MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION FOR SB- SB
EIGHTY SIX- IF SO PLEASE
INTRODUCE. THEM AND LET THEM
SPEAK. OKAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD. TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN AT
THIS TO. ONCE IT'S. ONE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A FEW COMING UP IN
JUST A MOMENT WHILE WE GIVE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBERS. THE
PROCEEDS WITH ONE AFTER THE
OTHER. ONE MOMENT HERE THEY'RE
JUST ABOUT BACK WITH US. OUR
FIRST IS GONNA COME FROM THE
LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ANTHONY MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
LINE. ONE MOMENT THEY'RE NOT
BACK WITH THIS. NEXT IS LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI VALERIE NARROW
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COM COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. NEXT IS
LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MICHAEL BELL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BY
VOTERS HAVE OPPOSED THANKS VERY
MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN
Q. THANK YOU- SO MODERATE. WE
WILL NOW ASK THE MEMBERS IF
THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. YES MISTER MATHIS.
ARM MR SURE I'D I'D LIKE TO IF
WE COULD HAVE- LAUREN COME BACK
ON WITH SOME OF THE FINDINGS TO
PAINT A BETTER PICTURE OF
FOLLOW WHAT YOUR NOLAN IF YOU.
TWENTY IT UP PLEASE COME ON THE
LINE AND FINANCIAL LAST NAME
PROPERLY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND MISTER CHAIR LAUREN
ONLY T. JACK. GO AHEAD MR
MATHIS WHAT WE HAD IF YOU COULD
KIND OF PAINT THE- A BETTER
PICTURE OF THE CURRENT USAGE OF
THE GRANULAR BECAUSE- MY
UNDERSTANDING AND BEING VICE
CHAIRMAN OF AGRICULTURE AND
THEN GOING ON MULTILATERAL
WRIST- WHEN WE DO APPLY. THIS
CHEMICAL IN A GRANULAR WAY-
THEY DON'T ALLOW ANYBODY OUT
THERE IN INTO THE FILTER INTO
THE ORCHARDS SHOW WHY WE ALL
KNOW- WE CAN GO OVER THE
FINDINGS ON. WHAT THE CHEMICAL
DOES AND BIRTH DEFECTS IN ALL
OF THESE THINGS BOY IT RAISES
THE QUESTION OF. HOW IS ANYBODY
OUT IN THE FIELD. IF THE FIELD
SHUT DOWN DURING A SPECIFIC
TIME AFTER THIS IS BEEN APPLIED
IT'S TO ME IT'S KIND OF LIKE-
WHEN IT WHEN HE YEAR HOUSE BLOG
FOR TERMITES OR SOMETHING YOU
KNOW YOU'RE NOT GONNA WALK
INSIDE OF IT SO WHY WOULD
ANYBODY BE OUT IN THIS FIELD-
ESPECIALLY FARMWORKERS IF THEY
KNOW THAT THIS IS BEEN APPLIED
SO CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN US A
LITTLE BIT MORE ON ON THAT FOR
OFFICE AND HOW THAT WORKS- FOR
THIS PARTICULAR REGULATION.
YEAH I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR THE QUESTION NOT
SAID VERY GOOD POINT YOU
DESCRIBED IT VERY WELL SO WHEN
IT COMES TO GRANULAR CORE
PURIFY US USE IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A VERY VERY LIMITED
CROPS BUT IT CAN ACTUALLY BE
USED ON AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE THERE'S NO RESIDENTIAL
USE ALLOWED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHEN IT IS BEING APPLIED TO
THIS SPECIFIC CROPS THAT IT'S
ALLOWED HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHAT
YOU FIRST HAVE TO DO IS GET AT-
A LICENSED. AS A SIDE-
REGISTRANT TO COME OUT THERE
AND ACTUALLY TELL YOU. YES YOU
NEED THIS FOR YOUR CROP THIS IS
WHY THIS IS THE SPECIFIC USE
AND THIS IS WHEN YOU SHOULD USE
THAT. AFTER YOU GET THAT PIECE
OF PAPER IT GETS REPORTED TO
YOUR LOCAL ACT COMMISSIONER THE
I. COMMISSIONER ALSO HAS TO
SIGN OFF. ON THE USE A GRANULAR
PER PURIFY US IN A WAY THAT
THAT PEST CONTROL ADVISER HAS
TOLD YOU THAT YOU CAN USE IT.
THEN IN ORDER TO APPLY IT TO
THE ACTUAL WHETHER THAT BE A
FIELD OR LIKE IN MY CLIENTS-
CITRUS USES IT. OCCASIONALLY
FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF ANTS- YOU
HAVE TO GET AND NOTIFY THE AYE
COMMISSIONER THAT YOU'RE USING
IT. THE TEN APPLYING IT HAS TO
BE. A LICENSE. IF I. TRAINING
SPECIAL TRAINING I MEAN IT'S
NOT JUST ANYONE WHO'S HANDED
THIS MATERIAL THEN THEY HAVE TO
APPLY IT EXACTLY HOW THE LABEL
TELLS THEM THAT THEY CAN APPLY
IT FOR THAT SPECIFIC CROP SO
EACH PESTICIDE HAS A LABEL THAT
GOES ALONG WITH IT. AND IF YOU
APPLY IT IN ANY WAY THAT'S
OUTSIDE OF THAT LABEL YOU ARE
OPEN TO HUGE LIABILITIES HUGE
FINES POTENTIAL JAIL TIME. ALL
OF THESE THESE TYPES OF
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS- ONCE YOU
APPLY IT BECAUSE IT IS A
RESTRICTED USE PESTICIDES THERE
HAS TO BE SIGNED INTO THAT IS
PUT. UP IN THE FIELDS NOTIFYING
PEOPLE THAT THE PESTICIDE HAS
BEEN APPLYING AND THAT THERE IS
NO ENTRANCE TO THE FIELD- FIRST
INTERESTS THAT A FIVE DAY
PERIOD WHERE NO ONE IS ALLOWED
TO GO BACK INTO THAT ORCHARD.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
NO EXPOSURE HAPPENING. IT'S
GOOD TO KNOW TOO THAT WITH
GRAMMAR PROCURE FOSS. WHAT IT
IS IT'S COATED. WITH THE ACTIVE
INGREDIENT CORKER POSSIBLE A
SMALL AMOUNT F IT AND THEN
IT'S A CLAY LIKE SUBSTANCE SO
THAT IT MAKE SURE IT STICKS IN
THE SOIL. AND THAT'S- BECAUSE
IT MITIGATE RISK OF GETTING ON
TO PEOPLE- IT SINKS INTO THE
SOIL SO IT'S REALLY GOING AFTER
THOSE ANTS. AND IT IT DOES IT'S
NOT GONNA GET INTO WATER OR
ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE. SO
THAT'S KIND OF THE WHOLE
PROCESS THAT GOES INTO IT AGAIN
YOU HAVE TO GET DON'T CHECK FOR
YOU TO APPLY THIS. ONE QUIET.
YOU HAVE TO ENTER THAT NO GOING
THE FIELD SIGN AND NOTICE IT
SHOULDN'T. USE I. WELL WHAT
DOES NOT IS. GET PEOPLE AND-
THANK YOU. ALL MISTER FOR GOT
GOT A FEW. I THANK YOU MISTER
COMING OUT OF THE OUT WORLD I
JUST WAS AT THE ALLMAN INPUT
THIS IS SOME IN A LARGER
BRIEFLY TOUCHED ON THE ANT
SITUATION WHEN YOU HARVEST-
ALMONDS. YOU SHAKE THEM OFF THE
TREE THEY FALL ON THE GROUND IF
YOU HAVE AN ANT PROBLEM WITHIN
THAT PARTICULAR PIECE OF
PROPERTY IT CAN BE ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING TO THE CROWD. IT'S
NOT JUST LIKE YOU LOSE A LITTLE
BIT YOU LOOKED A LOT AND CAN BE
ABSOLUTELY ECONOMICALLY
DEVASTATING TO THE GROWER IT
TOO IS EMPLOYEES AND ALL THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS. AS WELL AS HER
COMMENTS THAT. THERE IS A TIME
FOR. YOU HAVE TO TREAT THIS
PRIOR TO HARVEST. SO THE
CHEMICAL. THE CALL FOR IT'S
GONE BY THE TIME YOU GET THERE
SO. WHEN IT COMES TO. CROPS NOT
ALL CROPS ARE CREATED EQUAL.
SOME CROPS ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE. TO BUG DAMAGE THAN
OTHERS AND- THE M. INDUSTRY
USES US. VERY A SPARINGLY BUT
IT'S ALSO A TOOL IN OUR
TOOLBOX. AND IF WE TAKE THAT
TOOL WHERE IT ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATING FOR SHOULD. ONE
OTHER QUESTION TO FROM. THE
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR FOR THIS
SECOND BY WILL BE APPLE. THEN
AND NOW MAKE SURE YOU ASK
EARLIER BY OKAY I WANT. SINCE I
BELIEVE FLOOR QUESTION WERE
GERMANE TO ALL OUR LORD THAT'S
WHY I WANTED HAVE YOU FINISHED
WITH YOUR QUESTION SIR NO SIR
TOOLS BUT NOW THE MY MIKE IS
FOR THE SENATOR DO YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE ANY. EVIDENCE OF GRANULAR
BEING TRACKED BACK INTO HOMES
FOR ANY ANYTHING ALONG THOSE
LINES THAT YOU CAN REPORT TO US
ON. AS REGARDS THE FINDINGS. I
DON'T PERSONALLY I'D LIKE TO
ASK- MISTER JOHN OF YOU COULD
ANSWER THAT WITH REGARDS TO.
THIS TO CHANGE TAT INFORMATION
PLEASE ANSWER THE QUESTION. HI
AND- I THINK THAT THAT QUESTION
IS ACTUALLY BETTER DIRECTED
TOWARD TYLER- SMITH WHO IS WHO
HAS STUDIED THAT. YEAH BUT
THANK YOU THE- THERE ARE A
pMEANT THAT A LOOK NOT ONLY AT-
WORKERS EXPOSURE WHEN GRAIN
GRANULAR QUICKER OCCUPIED BUT
ALSO THE EXPO EUROPE THE
WORKERS AROUND ANYWHERE- WHERE
QUICKER ACOSTA DIVIDED MAYBE
WORKING EITHER ON YOUR BY FIELD
OR IN THE FIELD SOMETIME
AFTERWARD YOU AT THE YEAH LOOK
AT THAT THE TECHNICALLY. AND
THEY FOUND- NOT ONLY DID- ALL
OF THE GRAND NO ARE YOU THE
CLIP CARAFA THAT THEY'VE
APPROVED RESULT IN EXPOSURE OF
CONCERN BUT OF COMPOUND TO
WORKERS- BUT THEN. THE HI THE
PATH DOCTOR TO IT FOR THE-
ETHIC WITH ACT IT OFTEN IT
DOCTOR AND- FOR GRANULAR YOU
THE QUICKER. OUT GRANULAR YOU
WITH THOSE WORKERS THERE ON THE
IN ARE EXPOSED THEY AND HEY IT
AND THIRDLY WHAT ON THE
INTERNET THE CLOTHING AND GO
BACK HOME WE FAMILY MEMBERS MAY
EXPOSED WELL. BEING THAT WE
HAVE THE MOST HIGHEST
REGULATED- IN FRANKLY ARE ARE
DEPARTMENTS WORLD RENOWNED FOR
WHAT IT DOES DO YOU HAVE ANY.
ACTUAL EVIDENCE OF THIS
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA UNDER
THE CURRENT SYSTEM. A GUY I MET
IN THE MAKE UP MONEY DPR DID
NOT AT THAT GRANULAR QUITE
OFTEN WORKERS BURGER CO THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS EXPOSURE- SO
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO COMPLETE
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER THE- BUT
COMPREHENSIVE EFFECTIVELY HAVE
FROM YOU AT THE YEAH I. AND YOU
AT THE DAY LOW AT- OVER SEVENTY
DIFFERENT SCENARIOS MCCORMICK
GRANULAR THEIR PROPERTY USED
CLOTHING NONPROFIT LIKETHAT
CORRECT. AND THEY FOUND THAT
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT RECORDS
OKAY SO WE SO WE ALSO NARAL AND
NOT ACTUAL CASE STUDIES SO
THEREIS NO EVIDENCE THAT THIS
IS ACTUALLY AFFECTING.
CALIFORNIANS ARE CALIFORNIA.
FARMWORKERS THANK YOU. OKAY NOT.
HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION. OKAY
ANYONE ELSE. OKAY ONE TO REMIND
EVERY THAT THIS IS OF ON. GRANT
CLUB. WHAT COULD HAVE A
CHEMICAL TEACHER PLAN OF THE
DAILY RIGHT THIS IS A FAN
SIMPLY READ YEAH YOU CAN JUST
WHETHER YOU IT'S WORTH WHILE
HAVE THAT REPORT NINE. ASK YOU
TO VOTE ON. AND NOT IN A MATTER.
CASE WERE. IT SO THEY IS SIMPLY
A REPORT NOTHING MORE. THERE'S
ALSO A QUESTION OF- BECAUSE
THAT'LL BE UP TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND ULTIMATELY TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE DEPARTMENT IF THEY FEEL
WHICH TO GROW TO COST. RIGHT
NOW WHAT WILL BE CONSIDERING IS
SIMPLY WHETHER OR NOT IT IS
WORTHWHILE TO HAVE A QUARTERLY
REPORT. WE HAVE- MY-
INFORMATION- SO IF THEY'RE NO
MORE QUESTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
SENATOR TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- IT IS SIMPLY
INFORMATION THAT GETS PUBLICLY
INTO OUR HANDS SO THAT WE COULD
TRACK IS GRANULAR FORM OF
CHLORPYRIFOS- AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ASKING THROUGH SB EIGHTY
SIX AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR. SO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS TOPIC AND FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS I- DELAYED YOUR
BILL LAST YEAR IN TOTAL AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCH COULD WORK ON
IT I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
DOING THAT THIS YEAR THEN YOUR
MANAGER BILL. AND I ASKED THE
BILL MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS
BEGIN YOUR- AS IT DOES YOU
CONTINUE TO REFINE YOUR
FINDINGS TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
OF REFLECTIVE CURRENT SCIENCE
ON. FOUR ZERO FIVE. LIKE YOU
I'M VERY CONCERNED THAT THIS
CHEMICAL AND OTHER CHEMICALS
LIKE IF THE OTHER OF THEM OF
PHOSPHATE. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE EFFECTIVELY MONITORING
MANAGEMENT IN THE FUTURE.
REPORTS CAN BE COSTLY AND I
KNOW YOUR WORK CLOSELY WITH
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND
THE DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE REPORT PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL. IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY
TO MONITOR THE ISSUE.
RECOMMENDED NINE SO. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. IF THERE'S
NO OTHER COMMENTS I'D LIKE THE-
MATT IS JUST SECRETARY LIKE YOU
TO CALL THE ROLL IN THE MOTION
IS. MOTIONS FOR SECRETARY SB
EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
HOPE YOU THE PHARMACY RIGHT
WORK HI QUIRK HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I BACK IN OUR CAN I.
FLORA FLORIDA CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I. MATHIS NO AT THIS NO.
MURATSUCHI HI I'M I. OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I. SEVEN THE BILL TO.
SEVEN VOTES SEVEN BOATS
IMPASSES AND EVERYONE'S HERE SO
THAT THE- THAT AND SENATE BILL
OF RIGHTS MR HOLDER. WITH. I
WOULD CERTAINLY- HOBBY I WOULD
BE CERTAINLY GLAD TO HEAR FROM
THE PERSON IN THE AUDIENCE IF I
WAS. WHEN THIS. PLEASE YOU CAN
TESTIFYING NOW WE CAN STILL
HEAR IT. ONE THOUSAND ONE THE
NEXT ONE ALL RIGHT THAT'S FINE.
ONE FIVE. YOU ALSO. WHAT TIME
WAY TO. I APOLOGIZE. OKAY ALL
I'VE GOT ENOUGH TO ONE. OKAY WE
HAVE THANK YOU MATT BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER THANK YOU
FOR MEDICINE AND- ALL ALL MY
COLLEAGUES. WE NOW HAVE SB
THREE ONE TWO LEYVA. AS MANY
FRICTION FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR
INGREDIENT PRICING NO ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY. MOVE THE BILL.
FOR YOUR MAKE MY JOB EASY IF
YOU'RE MATHIS THE SECOND BY
MISTER REGULAR. AND FOR ABOUT
ALRIGHT WELL IF THE BILL'S
ALREADY BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
I WILL NOT WASTE YOUR TIME I
KNOW YOU HAVE A BUSY DAY I'LL
SAY THANK YOU IT'S VERY NICE TO
SEE ALL OF YOU- WHAT I WILL TO
SAY IS THE BILL DOES NOT BAN
ANY PRODUCT INGREDIENT OR
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL PRODUCT
LABELING. THIS WILL JUST MAKE
SURE THAT THE INGREDIENTS AND
FLAVORINGSARE POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN FIND
OUT WHAT'S IN THEIR FLAVORING I
USUALLY WE USUALLY BRING MY
LITTLE LIP GLOSS IT'S CALLED
STRAWBERRY FIZZ AND I WOULD
LOVE TO KNOW WHAT MAKES UP
STRAWBERRY PHYS. SO THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT AND WHAT ELSE FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SHOW- REMIND EVERYONE
THIS IS THE SAME BILL WE PASSED
OUT LAST YEAR. VERY CLOSE TO IT.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TO. SINCE OF.
THE FINANCIAL ONE. THE PHONE
LINE RENDON PUT ON THE LINE
WANT SCHIRMER MAYBE HALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EMAIL SALON
LEVERAGES MISTER SHARMA PLEASE
OR NEWS SHARMA AND- COURTESY.
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS WHAT THE SHARMA AND MY
EXPERTISE IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
TOXICOLOGY AND IMMUNOLOGY. AND
THE RESEARCH AND POLICY
CONSULTANT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HELP EMAIL ONE COLLABORATIVE
WHOSE MISSION IS TO ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY IN RIGHT AND
MAILING CHECKS ONE WORKERS MANY
OF WHOM ARE. PAGE AND THE-
OTHER WOMEN OF COLOR. I'M HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE ONE TWO AND I'LL MAKE
THIS SHORT. I REALIZE THAT YOU
QUALITY. THANK NATIONAL POLL ON
WORKERS THE RIGHT THAT THEY
NEED TO AVOID HARMFUL FRAGRANCE
AND FLAVOR INGREDIENTS AND
BEAUTY PRODUCTS THEY USE EVERY
DAY AT WORK AND THE POWER TO
SELECT PAPER PRODUCTS FOR THEIR
CLIENTS THE LACK OF FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE CREATES A
BUYER BEWARE SITUATION FOR
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS MAKING IT
IMPOSSIBLE THEM FOR THEM TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
INGREDIENTS ARE IN THE PRODUCTS
THEY USE. RENTALS ARE FOUND IN
OVER 95% OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS INCLUDING MOST NE'ER
NAIL AND HAIR SALON PRODUCT
THAT'S- ONE WORKERS FACE A
DOUBLE WHAMMY OF TOXIC
EXPOSURE. GIVEN THE YOUTH AND
BEAUTY PRODUCTS BOTH IN THEIR
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL LIFE.
NOT THE WORKPLACE SALON WORKERS
ARE EXPOSED TO FRAGRANCES MORE
THAN THE GENERAL POPULATION
WHICH ADDS TO THEIR ALREADY
DAILY EXPOSURE TO TOXIC
CHEMICALS. LABOR INGREDIENTS
CAN INCLUDE CHEMICAL THAT ARE
CLASSIFIED AS CARCINOGENS
REPRODUCTIVE DEVELOPMENTAL
TOXICANTS NEAR TALK AGAINST AN
ALLERGEN BY A DOOR TATE OF
SCIENTIFIC BODIES IN FACT
RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT HAIR
STYLIST AND BEAUTICIAN HOBBY
FORTY SEVEN TIMES HIGHER RISK
OF FRAGRANT SKIN ALLERGIES.
THAN PEOPLE IN OTHER
OCCUPATIONS ANY THIRD OF ALL
FRAGRANCE CHEMICALS CURRENTLY
IN USE HAVE BEEN FLAG AT THE
TENSION LIKE TOXIC BY
SCIENTISTS AROUND THE WORLD.
FINALLY THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED OUR
SOCIETIES PUBLIC HELP BUT
WONDER ABILITY AND INEQUITIES
WITH RESPECT TO CODE NINETEEN
TOXIC CHEMICALS AND PERSONAL
CARE AND BEAUTY PRODUCTS ARE
PART OF THE PROBLEM WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE NOT ALONE WORKERS
ARE MADE UP OF POPULATION WHO
ALREADY BEAR A DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN OF TOXIC EXPOSURES. NOW
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE IS SHOWING
THAT THERE CLOSER TO ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTING COMPOUNDS FOUND IN
FRAGRANCE PRODUCT ADD TO THEIR
DAILY BODY BURDEN OF TOXIC
EXPOSURE AND MAY AFFECT THEIR
IMMUNE SYSTEM DEFENSE
EXASPERATING THEIR
VULNERABILITY. OF THE NINETEEN
WE BELIEVE THAT CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW IF
HARMFUL INGREDIENTS ARE IN THE
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS BRING HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND YOU DALY IN THEIR
WORKPLACES AND URGE YOU TO VOTE
I ON SB. THREE ONE TWO THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. OUR PRO
MODERATOR PLEASE FEDERAL THE
LINE JANET MIDDLEMAN ON BEHALF
OF BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS. IS MAY WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
DOCTOR QUIRK AND THANK YOU TO
THE ASTM COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JANET NEWMAN AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMMING POLICY
OPPRESSED CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS WE ARE ONE OF THE NGOS
SPONSORS OF SB THREE TWELVE ON
BEHALF OF B. C. P. P. AND THE
OTHER THREE BILL SPONSORED
WOMEN'S VOICES FOR THE EARTH
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS AND
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL
SALON COLLABORATIVE. WE WANTED
THANK SENATOR LEYVA FOR HER
STEADFAST LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL
AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
STM COMMITTEE FOR HEARING IT
GIVEN HOW TO. ALLOCATED YOUR
COMMITTEE SCHEDULE HAS BECOME
IN LIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC ARE
QUITE SIMPLY THIS IS A GREAT
BILL WITH BROAD BASED SUPPORT
COMING FROM EIGHTY TWO
ORGANIZATIONS AND BUSINESSES AS
DIVERSE AS THE WOOD LANE
COALITION FOR GREEN SCHOOLS
YOLO COUNTY. TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEADERS CONSERVATION VOTERS TO
YOU CAN ONLY BURKE I CAN'T
LARGEST OF MATTER COMPANY IN
THE WORLD CLASS THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ON
RECORD WHICH THE UNIVERSAL WELL
OF AND BENEFITS OF FRAGRANCE
AND FLAVOR INGREDIENT
DISCLOSURE IN AND PERSONAL
TOPICS. WITH YOUR I CAL WILL
WANT TO BE THE WAY AND SETTING
A HIGH BAR GRITTY AND
TRANSPARENT ONLY CALIFORNIANS
FOR CAN. SALON WORKERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
I TELL IN ADVANCE AND DOCTOR
QUIRK I JUST WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT I'M ALSO AVAILABLE
CHIU REGISTER DAHLE NEED SHOES
IN SUPPORT OF THE DEL ARE WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO HEAR THEM. NOW
WHAT. GO AHEAD. OH OKAY I'M SO
THERE ARE EIGHTY TWO OUR
BUSINESS AND THEN OR IN OF BELL
HAVE A FEW YOU GO WANT IT READ
THEM ALL. FOR WOULD BE A PLAN
I'LL GO HIGHLIGHT A FEW YEAH AT
OF THE HOW SO. IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWELVE INCLUDE THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION. THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ASSOCIATION. OF THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ASTHMA
COLLABORATIVE. I FEW OF THE KEY
LABOR AND CONSUMER
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT INCLUDE
WORK SAFE THE NATIONAL ON QUOTE
EMPLOYMENT LAWCENTER. AND THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. JUST A FEW OF THE
LEADING ENVIRONMENTAL AND
CONSERVATION GROUPS AND SUPPORT
INCLUDE THE SIERRA CLUB THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER ACT. A LOT. THE N. E. W.
G. I'M FINALLY THERE ARE TWENTY
BUSINESS SUPPORTING THREE
TWELVE INCLUDING LEADING CLEAN
COSMETICS COMPANIES LIKE BEAUTY
COUNTER DR BRONNER'S IO SEVENTH
GENERATION BADGER 1100% HERE
AND THREE CONVENTIONAL
COSMETICS COMPANY STORY OF THE
LARGEST IN THE WORLD UNILEVER
PROCTER AND GAMBLE AND CLOROX
THE MAKER OF BURKE SPEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELL NOW LOOK FOR
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE EVERYONE IN THE FORTY TO
WORK TO WHICH IS. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. FORTY FOUR OKAY COME
UP TO THE MICROPHONE PLEASE.
NOW NOW YOU IF YOU CAN GIVE
YOUR NAME. AND ANY ORGANIZATION
BUT THAT'S ALL JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION WHETHER YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THAT'S
ALL SO WHEN I WAS IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE I GOT FIVE MINUTES
WITH KEN COOLEY WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE THIS IS A DIFFERENT.
THIS IS STANDARD ROOMS- FOR
POLICY COMMITTEE. TO GET TO SO
NAME ORGANIZATION THE FAMILY.
AND WHAT DO YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THAT'S IT. I'M SORRY.
NOT PLEASE GIVE ME YOUR NAME. I
THINK YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. MANY ORGANIZATION
MIGHT BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF.
MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRONG.
MY AFFILIATION IS THE MOTHER OF
FOUR CHILDREN AND I'M MARRIED
TO A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER. AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF I CHANGE MY MIND CAN I COME
BACK TO THE MICROPHONE. IF YOU
WANT TO BE IN A POSITION THIS
WOULD BE THE FIRST TIME I'VE
EVER SEEN SOMEONE. LET'S SEE I
THOUGHT I GOT A MINUTE AND
YOU'RE NOT GIVING. PLEASE SIT
DOWN. MORE RIGHT. RIGHT WE HAVE
ONE WITNESS ON THE PHONE PHONE
LINE TESTIFYING. NEW TRACK ON
NEUTRALITY. PHONE MODERATOR
PLEASE PUT ON THE NOT ON THE
LINE NICOLE. HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE FRAGMENTS
CREATORS ASSOCIATION MISSILE
KNOWN YOU MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU KAREN
NUMBER MY NAME IS NICOLE KIANA
ON BEHALF OF THE SECOND
CREATORS WITH EACH ONE AND AS
YOU KNOW IT WE ARE NEUTRAL ON
AT THE THREE AND WE DID WANTED
TO THE COPPER. TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. WHERE ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR WORK
ABOUT YEAR AND A HALF WHICH GOT
IT TO THE- ABLE TO REMEMBER
OPPOSITION. IT WILL BE SHOWN ON
THE PORT MEANING IN.
COMMUNICATE WHAT AT THE THREE
TWELVE EIGHTEEN THANK YOU CAN
MATCH SO BONE MODERATOR WE OF
ANY WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE
WHO ALSO WANT TO SPEAK- AS
NEUTRAL PARTY. ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OUR
FIRST WILL COME FROM NO. WOULD
FIRST WILL COME FROM LINE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. INCLUDE FORTY DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
YOU'RE SHOULD COUNCILIN
SUPPORT OF THE THREE TOP THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I'M SORRY. I
SHOULD HAVE HAS FOR SUPPORT
PRIOR SO LET YEARS NOW FOR AN
SIX ON THE PHONE LINES THANK
WHICH IS WORTH FULLY WANT TO ON
THE LINE. OKAY IF YOU ARE A SO.
PLEASE PRESS. THEN NEXT IS LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THE
CALIFORNIA CAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE LINE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR NUMBER IF MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION BOARD BETTER AND
STRONGER FORD AT THREE TWELVE
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT THEN DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE
WHICH IS TO SPEAK AND WHO IS
NEUTRAL. WHO SB THREE ONE TWO.
ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE NEUTRAL. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. AND THEN IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK
OPPOSITION. THREE ONE THREE. IT
IS. HING I NAY. YEAH WELL I
DON'T THINK. IF YOU IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE AHEAD. MY
NAME IS STILL ANDREA HAD STRONG.
I'M STILL THE MOTHER OF FOUR
CHILDREN. AND I'M STILL MARRIED
TO A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER THAT
IS MY AFFILIATION. AND I'M
AGAINST THIS BILL BECAUSE I'M
AND GUESTS THIS LEGISLATURE
INJECTING TOXINS INTO OUR
CHILDREN. THAT KILLS THEM. AND
THEN MESSING WITH THIS. PLEASE
SIT DOWN. AND WHERE'S MY HEAD
KIM AND- I WATCHED ONE MINUTE.
IF YOU CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT I
WILL ASK YOU CAN ALSO. I'LL BE
RIGHT. CHINA'S HIGHER IF YOU'RE
ALL. I WASN'T SURE WHETHER WE
WERE COMMUNISTS OR WORK RIGHT
WING STOOGES BUT WHATEVER. SO
CALLED MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE OPPOSITION
SB THREE ONE TWO. PRESS ONE
ZERO FOUR OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CRYSTAL HER ERA
AND I WANT TO START OFF BY
SAYING THAT YOU GUYS SHOULD BE
AS- CONCERNED ABOUT THE TOPIC
THAT YOU GUYS INJECT INTO OUR
CHILDREN AND THE TOPIC THAT YOU
READ ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
MAKE MAKE UP PRODUCTS. SO I AM
TRYING I HOPE THIS BILL BECAUSE
YOU GUYS NEED TO HAVE OTHER
CONCERNS THAT ARE MORE
IMPORTANT. LIKE DAMAGING AND
KILLING OUR CHILDREN. WELL WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK OPPOSITION FROM
MODERATOR. WE HAVE ONE MORE
LINE IN Q. ITS LINE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS KAREN CAMPBELL I'M A
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIANS WHO IS
REGISTERING COULD BE AGAINST
THIS BILL. CLICK TO OUR
CHILDREN. WORKING. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
WELL IT'S BEEN VERY EXCITING.
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE THE-
FRANK FIRST QUESTIONS YES
MISTER OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. SENATOR I
THINK YOU AND I HAD A
DISCUSSION LAST YEAR BUT THIS
BILL AND I'M A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED BECAUSE I MASS IN
QUESTION THAT I ASKED YOU YOU
GO AND- HOPE THE THAT WE CAN
KIND OF RESOLUTION AND NOW THE
BILL APPLIES TO. MANUFACTURE OF
A COSMETIC PRODUCTS SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA BUT SOLD AS WITH A
LOWER CASE SAYS IT'S NOT
DEFINED IN THE BILL CAN YOU.
TELL ME WHAT WHAT YOUR
CONCEPTION OF THE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT THE MEANING OF SOLD IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS. THAT I
THINK PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
I'M SORRY YOU'RE DISAPPOINTED-
IT'S A LITTLE IT'S PRETTY
STRAIGHT. IT HAS TO BE SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT CALIFORNIA
WE'RE ARE LEGISLATING
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW. OUR HOPE
IS THAT OTHER LEGISLATURES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WILL DECIDE
TO DO THE SAME. SO HERE'S MY
CONCERN. IF THERE'S AN
INTERMEDIARY LIKE A DISTRIBUTOR
IN THE DISTRIBUTOR PURCHASES
PRODUCTS FROM A MANUFACTURER IN
FLORIDA. AND UNBEKNOWNST TO
THAT MANUFACTURER DISTRIBUTOR
SELLS THOSE PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA HOW WITH THE
MANUFACTURE IN FLORIDA. NO THAT
THAT WERE SUBJECT TO THE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
LAW. WELL I DON'T KNOW. AND I
THINK I GAVE YOU THAT SAME
ANSWER LAST YEAR. OKAY BUT I
MEAN I THINK IT WOULD BEEN
EASILY NOT EASY ENOUGH TO SAY
KNOWINGLY SELLS OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT JUST TO. TO ESTABLISH
THAT CONNECTION THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO IN FOR
SOMETHING ABOUT AGAINST TO
MANUFACTURE THERE'S NO DEA
THEIR PROPERTY BEING
DISTRIBUTED HERE. BOB THANK YOU
SO AND I HAVE TO ASK BECAUSE-
THIS IS A GOVERNMENT OBVIOUSLY-
THIS THIS BILL. I DON'T THINK
SO. I MEAN IT WHEN. DID WE GET
AMENDED BECAUSE IT WAS WE HAD A
LOT YEAR. AND I GOT HELD SO WE
JUST USED A DIFFERENT VEHICLE.
THAT'S RIGHT SO THE- OF WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT THE AYE AYE.
THE REASON I BROUGHT IT UP AS I
LOVED THIS BILL THE CONTENTS
THE BILL BEFORE US. ESTABLISHED
A- A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
PROVISION OF SERVICE DOGS TO
VETERANS. I LOVE THAT BILL AND
I JUST HAVE TO ASK WHAT
HAPPENED TO IT BECAUSE- I WAS
LOOKING FORWARD TO BOOK- WE
LOVE THAT BILL TO WE HAD ON
THERE WERE NUMEROUS PROBLEMS.
ACTUALLY THE ASSEMBLY WITH THAT
BILL- THE VETERANS COMMITTEE
DID NOT LOVE THE BILL AND SO. I
THOUGHT THAT WE COULD ALREADY.
MONEY THE WE WERE LOOKING FOR.
THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS ALREADY
OUT THERE AND THAT WE COULD
HELP VETERANS GROUPS APPLY FOR
THAT. MONEY I WAS EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTED WELL I LOW THAT
BILL TO. IT GOT. IT GOT HELD
WAS A MOVE ANY FARTHER BECAUSE
IT SO IT WAS GOING TO DIE IN
THE ASSEMBLY. SO WE USED IT FOR
SOMETHING ELSE. I WOULD
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
REDUCE IT WHEN FISCAL TIMES ARE
BETTER. I THOUGHT WHAT'S GREAT
IDEA AND IT WASN'T EVEN A
FISCAL ISSUE IT WAS JUST THAT.
THE VETERANS COMMITTEE THOUGHT
THAT. WOULD THAT IT. THAT IT
WAS. DUE TO PUT DUPLICATIVE THE
DAY THESE GROUPS. HI FOR THAT
MONEY I DIDN'T THINK THAT WE
DIDN'T THINK THAT BUT- THEY DID
SO. THAT'S HAPPENED UP THERE
WAS A GREAT IDEA THANK YOU
WITHOUT SO ANYONE ELSE. SENATOR
LEYVA YOU MAY CLOSE SPEC MASS
FOR NIGHT OF A SORRY FOR THE
DRAMA. RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS. MEASURES FOR AND
FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK AND
THEN WE DID PASSES SUBCOMMITTEE
EIGHT LAST YEAR. BY THE WAY
JUST SOLD SOLD AT RETAIL WAS
THAT. WHICH IS THE COMMON SENSE
SORT OF DEFINITION. YEAH IT'S
JUST IT SOLD IN CALIFORNIA SO
IT COULD MOSTLY WILL BE OLD IN
RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS BUT I
MEAN WE DO KNOW THE PEOPLE BUY
PRODUCTS ON AMAZON AND WHATNOT
SO. ALL RIGHT- SO I RECOMMENDED
NINE VOTE. MISTER SECRETARY-
THE TO WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND SO- PLEASE REFER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. SB
THREE TWELVE LEYVA THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK QUIRK II ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA II BACK IN THEIR QUE
HAN I. FLORA FLOOR NOT VOTING.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I MATHIS
MATHIS I NURSE TWO G. THREE G.
HI OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NOT
VOTING. SEVEN VOTES WHAT THEIR
PASSION FOR EVERYONE HERE. WELL
WE CAN NOW GO TO THE FINAL BILL
WILL BE HEARING TODAY SB TEN
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALAN AS
WAS A THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS EVERYONE STAY
SAFE. THE SENATE. FIREFIGHTING
AND TWO FIVE NUMBER FOR SO. HI
I HAVE VERY GOOD MORE TO
EVERYONE MEMBERS AND- THANK YOU
FOR SHOULD THE THEM THE MOTION.
WE JUDGE WE JUST GO THROUGH THE
TROUBLE FOR SO FOR EVERYONE IS
HERE ON SENATOR ALLEN FOOD IF
YOU'RE A FAN YOU KNOW I HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THE FIREFIGHTERS
ON THIS AND SO FORTH. INSTEAD
WE WERE WITH ALL THE STATE TO.
IN FOR A LOT OF. SO I WANT TO
THANK AS WELL THE STATE TO
PERSEVERE ON THIS. I UNDERSTAND
YOU'VE MADE SIGNIFICAN PROGRESS
IN NEGOTIATIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT THOSE
IN MORE DETAIL. AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD PLEASE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH MY COMMITTEE STAFF
GO AHEAD MR ALLEN YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER. WELL OKAY WE'LL
FIND THE TIME BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'VE WORKED VERY HARD WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS YEAH AND I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I WANT TO ALSO A PERSONALLY
THINK YOU MAY CARE AND ALSO
YOUR YOUR GREAT- COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
YOU'VE PUT IN. HELPING TO
CONVENE EVERY AND GET US TO
HAVE WHAT I THINK NOW WE NOW
STRUCK A DEAL WHICH I'M I'M
VERY PLEASE IT'S STILL. VERY
MUCH MAINTAINS THE INTEGRITY OF
THE BILL SO. ON THIS THIS BILL
HAS TO DO WITH P. FOSTER IT'S A
IT'S A CARCINOGENIC- CHEMICAL
THAT IS I HAVE BEEN FOUND IN.
FIREFIGHT QUIT FIREFIGHTING
FOAM FORTUNATELY IT GETS INTO
OUR GROUND WATER SUPPLY IN AND
pFIRST. TO IF YOU WANNA KNOW
MORE ABOUT THE D. ASSOCIATED P.
FIVE OF THERE'S A FAINT A
DOCUMENTARY ON. YOU WATCH ALL
THE- WE- IT'S ABOUT. AND THE
EXTENT TO WHICH IT WAS CAUSING
CANCER AND A WHOLE ZONE. OF
APPALACHIA- SO WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO PHASE OUT
THESE CHEMICALS. REACHED OUT
SEVERAL YEARS AGO EITHER
WORKING ON THIS FOR A COUPLE
YEARS NOW TO THE FIREFIGHTERS.
THEY OBVIOUSLY CARE A LOT
ABOUT. GETTING CANCER TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW BUT THEY CARE
MORE ABOUT MAKING SURE THEY
DON'T GET BURNED RIGHT THEN AND
THERE WITH THE FIRING FOR
THEMSELVES. RASCAL SLIPPING YES
YES SORRY SORRY SIR SO- SO WITH
SO OBVIOUSLY THEY THEY
ULTIMATELY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE GOOD
ALTERNATIVES OUT THERE THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE
THEIR IMPORTANT WORK IN
FIGHTING FIRES WHILE ALSO AT
THE SAME TIME- PROTECTING THEIR
MEMBERS FROM FROM FROM CANCER
QUITE FRANKLY AND SO- AFTER
MANY WEEKS AGO SHE SHINS WITH-
WITH VARIOUS. FOLKS INCLUDING
FROM THE THIS IS THE TIME
ASSOCIATION AT THE OPPOSITION
COALITION I BELIEVE WE RECENT
AGREEMENT ARE THE AMENDMENTS
ARE WILL BE PUT INTO PRINT
APPROPRIATIONS BUT THE CHANGES
INCLUDE EXACTING AND STORAGE IN
THE POOL AT ALL RIGHT. CENTER
TRUST WELL REFINERS IN
TERMINALS OUT TO TWENTY THIRTY
TWO WHICH INCLUDES INCREASE
DISCRETION BY THE FIRE MARSHAL
BUT THE IDEA BEING. THAT THEY
CAN ONLY GRANT THIS WAIVER- IF
THERE THERE'S NOT A GOOD
ALTERNATIVE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE FOLKS CAN FIVE
FIRES AT REFINERIES OBVIOUSLY.
THAT'S THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
OUR PROVIDING A THREE YEAR
DELAY FOR P. FOSS PHONE PHASE
OUT STRUCTURE SO THAT IF YOU
HAVE A FIXED PHONES SUPPRESSION
SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE SO TO
ACCOMMODATE WITH. BY OUR CAN
CAN PLAN AND- IS IT. PHONE
AFTER FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS ARE
CHANGED. SO WITH THESE CHANGES
THE BILL PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
TIME FLEXIBILITY FOR INDUSTRY
TO TRANSITION FROM P. FOSS
PHONES. AND PROVIDES IMPORTANT
CONTAINMENT PROVISIONS FOR ANY
USES BEYOND TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
TO PREVENT THE RELEASE OF THE
FOAM INTO THE ENVIRONMENT. HI
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE- WATER
AGENCIES ARE SUPPORTING THE
BILL BECAUSE GIVEN THE
CONTAMINATION LEVELS IN OUR
DRINKING WATER THE LEAST WE CAN
DO IS STOP MAKING THE PROBLEM
WORSE. THE LONGER WE WAIT THE
MORE PEOPLE WILL BE EXPOSED IN
FACE LIFELONG HEALTH AFFECTS.
NOW IS THE TIME TO STAND UP FOR
OUR FIREFIGHTERS FOR CHILDREN
ARE COMMUNITIES FROM THIS
UNNECESSARY SOURCE. OF PEACE.
OSHA THE FACT IS THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES OUT THERE. THEY
CAN BE USED TO FIVE FIRE
SAFELY. THAT WON'T CAUSE.
CANCER AND BIRTH DEFECTS. AND
SO ON THE CONFERENCE LINE-
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE- DEREK. IRWIN WHO'S A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FIREFIGHTER WE
ALSO HAVE. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT DOCTOR AND READ. A
STAFF SCIENTIST WITH A NATIONAL
RESEARCH COUNCIL. VERY GOOD
PHONE MODERATE- MODERATOR WHO'S
BUT ALL ALONG MISTER JACK-
MISTER IRWIN NAY TO SHE'D WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. DOCTOR QUIRK OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR ALLOW ME A MOMENT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY FOUR MY NAME IS DEREK
CALLING WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL TEN
FOURTEEN. I HOLD A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN CHEMISTRY AND I'M IN
THE FINAL YEAR OF MY PHD
STUDIES WHERE MY RESEARCH
EXAMINES HOW CHEMICALS
ENCOUNTERED BY FIREFIGHTERS
CALLED DNA DAMAGE. AND I ALSO
LOST MY YOUNGER BROTHER TO
CANCER WHEN HE WAS JUST THIRTY
THREE YEARS OLD. PUBLIC IS.
AWARE THAT WE FIVE. ARE LIFE ON
THE LINE DALY READILY. THE
DANGER OF FIRE BECAUSE- OUR DO
YOU. ALAS KNOWN DANGER THAT WE
FACE IS ELEVATE RATE OF CANCER
THE FIRE SERVICE. NUMEROUS
STUDIES HAVEFOUND OCCUPATIONAL
LINKED TO SEVERAL CANCERS AMONG.
IN CANCER IS ONE OF THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IN OUR LINE OF
WORK. ARE ELEVATED LEVELS OF
CANCER. AFRICAN EXPOSURE TO
CARCINOGENS ARE SUCH THAT THE
INTERNATIONAL AGENCY FOR
RESEARCH ON CANCER. ACTUALLY
CLOCK BY FIRE FIGHTING THE
POSSIBLY CARCINOGENIC
OCCUPATION. FRANK THIS IS THE
BEST PLACE TO FIND IN THE WORLD
TO SPEC THAT OUR LINE OF WORK
CAUSE CANCER. MANY CRAPPIE FIRE
FIGHTING FOAMS KICKING PEOPLE
OFF CHEMICALS THAT HAVE BEEN
LINKED TO SEVERAL TYPES OF
CANCER. AND A VARIETY OF OTHER
HEALTH PROBLEMS. FOR THE MORE
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT OUR
FIREFIGHTING PP THE EQUIPMENT
UPON WHICH WE RELY TO DO OUR
JOBS CAN CONTAIN. CHEMICALS
CHEMICAL ATTACK NOT ONLY
FIREFIGHTERS BUT EVERY MEMBER
OF EVERY COMMUNITY THAT WAS
SIR. THESE FIREFIGHTERS WILL
ALWAYS PUT OUR DUTY TO PROTECT
PUBLIC FIRST SO WITHOUT
HESITATION WERE REPEATEDLY
EXPOSED TO CONDITION THE
INCREASE OUR RISK OF BEING
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER ONE DAY.
AS A RESULT WE NEED TO MAKE UP
GROUND IT OUT AGAIN CANCER THE
FIRE SERVICE BY MINIMIZING OUR
EXPOSURE TO CARCINOGENS
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. ELIMINATING
OR REDUCING EXPOSURE TO PEOPLE
OF CHEMICALS AND FIRE FIGHTING
FOAMS AN INCREASE IN AWARENESS
ABOUT THE PRESENCE OF PEOPLE
CAN. AND GEAR. WILL HELP MAKE
UP SOME OF THE- WELL IN THE
FIRE SERVICE ALWAYS DE READY TO
HELP. I NEED THIS IS WHERE WE
NEED YOUR HELP. OUR EFFORTS TO
STOP THE CAMP BUT EVENTUALLY BE
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES WITHOUT
MOTHERS OR FATHERS WITHOUT SONS
OR DAUGHTERS. FOR THESE REASONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. TEN FORTY FOUR. THANK
IRWIN FOLLOW MODERATOR FOR
ONLINE ORDERING ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL THREE OF US PLEASE
PROCEED. HERE ARE GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME OF ANNA
READ AND I'M A SCIENTIST AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND- WE FIND TO FUND
PIZZA. I LOVE THE DOCTOR TO AND
ABOUT THE FILE. ON INDEPENDENT
TRYING TO ARE THIRTY OF BODY
INCLUDING DEPARTMENT EXCEPT
CONTROL CONCLUDED THE FAST
ARTICLE BUT THE SCARY THING BY
MENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT
TRANSACTION PERSISTENT. BUT I
BODIES EDUCATED WITH AWAY ARRAY
OF HARMFUL EFFECTS. INCLUDING
CANCER INSISTENCE QUESTION COME
OUT FIRST ABOUT MENTAL FAX.
STATE DRINKING WATER TESTING
SHOWS TO DATE. THE PUBLIC WATER
CONSERVING UP TO NINETEEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE
SOURCES THAT ARE CONTAMINATED
WITH PIZZA AND WITH ONLY THE
FIRST BETA TESTING IN THIS
NUMBER WILL LIKELY INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY. DATA SHOWS THAT
MUCH OF THE PEOPLE OF POLLUTION
INCLUDING MAJOR SOURCES ARE IN
OR NEAR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ALREADY DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY POLLUTION OF ALL
KINDS. IN ADDITION TO
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH IMPACT COST
THE BEST POLLUTION LOOK IMPOSE
MASSIVE CLEAN ACROSS THE STATE.
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS IN OTHER
STATES. AND COUNTRY INCLUDING
THE EU I CONCLUDED THAT CORN
THREE FIREFIGHTING FROM ARE
VIABLE AVAILABLE AND ECONOMICAL
WITH TEMPORARY LIMITED CAPTION.
FOR EXAMPLE KOREAN THREE PHONE
COMPANIES EXACTLY AIRCRAFT
FIRED A LARGE ENOUGH FOR OUR
INVOLVING PALM OIL AND
FERTILIZER AND CHEMICAL FACTORY
FIRE NUMBER. OF JOY YOU HAVE
PASSED LAWS LEAVING OUT THE BOX
CONTAINING FROM AS MANY
PROMINENT COMPANIES INCLUDING
OIL AND CHEMICAL COMPANIES ARE
ALREADY USING FOR YOU FREE
FALL. APART FOR CALIFORNIA TO
CATCH UP TO THE OTHER STATE AND
COUNTRY THEN DO IT PART. SOME
OF THE MAJOR AGAIN. OF FOR
ALTERNATIVE AVAILABLE. THE
DOCTOR CAN CAUSE THAT ME AND
BURN FOR HOW TO THOUSANDS OF
YOUR- I KNOW THEY CONSTRUCTION
TECHNOLOGY HAS YET BEEN
IDENTIFIED. HOW DECIDE YOU'D
REGULATED CHEMICALS NOW HOW FAR
REACHING CONSEQUENCES FOR
DECADES TO COME SB TEN FORTY
FOUR AND THE UNNECESSARY THE
PEOPLE FIREFIGHTING FROM. AND
PROTECT OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND
OUR COMMUNITY TO NEW CARPET
TROPICAL. FINALLY HAVE AN AFTER
LIFT A TO THE- REPORT TEN FOR
ONE OF HER. YOU MAY READ THAT
NOW. OKAY THANK YOU ARE BUT CAN
PREVENT PARTNER CLEAN WATER
ACTION ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP BUT KANTOR ACTION
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER CENTER FOR PUBLIC
ENVIRONMENTAL OVERSIGHT
CALIFORNIA COOKIE PER LINE THE
FOR STATE NATIONAL SEARCH
ACTION. FIND POLICY INSTITUTE
CAL HEALTHY MALE ONE
COLLABORATIVE FAVOR SHORT
POLLUTION COALITION FOUNDER FOR
A OCEANIC AWARENESS RESEARCH.
THE FIVE YEARS IF YOU SOME
GENERATION BY THEIR PRODUCT
THERE'S A COUNT OF HEALTH CARD
CAMPUS GO BACK FRIEND'S ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA YOUR
CALL CALIFORNIA DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE THANK YOU FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ONE PLACE
BUT IF YOU WERE CHIU.
CALCULATOR FULLY EIGHT ZERO. GO
BAY AREA TRY TO THIS WAS OF
RESPONSIBILITY CAL INDIAN BY I
OR OREGON COUNCIL BUT THEY
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
ASSOCIATES CAUSTIC OCEAN
INTERNET OPS. SO JUNE RUSSIA
ASIAN AND ARE WAYS USA THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
ALRIGHT TIME SO FOR MODERATOR
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TEN FORTY FOUR IF SO PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO HAVE IF. OKAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT ONE ZERO.
OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM THE
LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR AND
MEMBERS THE MILLION ON BEHALF
OF THE SENATE VALLEY WATER
AGENCY SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE. TWENTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST MUCH
LONGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAKING THROUGH WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
GOING TO LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- RICHARD GLOWGAZE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RYAN AND JACK CAME WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR QUIRK IN
MEMBERS THERE DAHLE CAN HAPPEN
LEGAL CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR OPENING LINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS AFFECT MARKETS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S THE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG. NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN QUIRK A COMMITTEE
MEMBER MY NAME IS BRADY
THOMPSON BUT METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND I'M HERE TO VOICE PUT YOU
CAN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU. WE
GO TO LINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOCTOR NEAR- GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS CLICK IT OFF ON BEHALF
OF NATIONAL ACTION CAMP WHAT
CAN HELP YOUR PRODUCT REACHES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIX NEXT
IS LAW IS THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR CA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS ALL PART OF TRIMMING TOOK
THE UP THE OF YOUR LONG TERM.
WE'RE OPPOSED GREAT WERE FROM
THE. MR OF THE GENERAL STAFF AS
WELL AS THE SPONSOR. WE'RE NOW
IN SUPPOSED TO THANK YOU MUCH
FOR THEIR MUCH. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN KEY. THANK YOU
REMEMBER HEAR FROM- WESTERN
STATE PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL I
HAVE BEEN IN OPPOSITION I HOPE
THEY HAVE- REACHED AGREEMENT
WITH YOU OFFER OFFER AND SO-
FIRST WE'LL HEAR FROM MODEL
PARKS ON BEHALF THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
THE MOST PARKS ARE YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARGOT PARKS WITH THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION AND FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND THE
AUTHOR AND BOTH OF THEIR STAFF
FOR ALL THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE WELL I THINK THAT- THE
CHAIRMAN AND AUTHOR HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED THE TREMENDOUS
EFFORT THAT HAD GONE INTO
CONTRIBUTIONS OVER THE PAST.
MONTH I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO
RESOLUTION ON THE ISSUE AND
THAT ISSUE IS ONE OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE FOR INDUSTRY FROM
ABOUT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE WITHOUT WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK AND THAT. I
WOULD FALLING KNOWLEDGES IN.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE TOPIC.
SUPPORT CHECKING TO BE FOUND
FOR TRAINING PER. YEAH AND HAVE
AND HAVE BANNED THAT YOU FOR
YEARS NOW. AND WHILE CHLORINE
FREE PHONES ARE BEING DEVELOPED
AND WHILE THE INDUSTRY HADN'T
HAPPENED EARLY IN THE DOLLARS.
INTO KATHLEEN WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE. INVOLVED FOR
ALL YOUTH ISN'T SO AND HELP
SUCH A TIME AS ALTERNATIVES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ASKING FOR
CONTINUED ALBEIT- LIMITED YOU
UNDER. EMERGENCY SITUATION. AND
I THINK AS THE SENATOR
KNOWLEDGE PUTTING REFINERY. IS
EXTRAORDINARILY. PLAY GET AND
BUT PRACTICE. MANY PARKING
FACILITIES COMMUNITY. SO I AS I
MENTIONED I BELIEVE WE MADE
FROM PROP ON THAT ISSUE AND
LOOKING FORWARD. CONTINUING TO
WORK ON WITH THE AUTHOR AND
MONSTER'S OF THAT MEASURE SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WONDERING
PLEASE FEDERAL. FEDERAL THAT.
ON THE OF THE NOW CHEMISTRY CAL
MISTER JESTER OF PLEASE WITH
TESTING. YOU ARE VERY MUCH ARE
QUIRK CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS I CAN
CAN SHE THINK WITH THE AMERICAN
CAN COUNCIL I TO ONE OF PER
THOUGHT THANK CENTER ALLEN HIS
STAFF COMMITTEE STAFF TO IN THE
SPONSORS FOR ENGAGING IN A VERY
THOUGHTFUL DIALOG DURING THE
PAST. SEVERAL WEEKS WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS IN DETAIL THE CONCERN
WE HAVE THE BILL IT WAS
ORIGINALLY DRAFTED AND DIALOGUE
ON LANGUAGE. TO I'M IN A GROUP.
OF THIS PARK ON THE NEED TO
TAKE ADDITIONAL. TO ENSURE THAT
THE RELEASE OF SOFT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT IS CONTAINED- WHILE
FULLY FORTY THREE PHONES ARE
AVAILABLE IN MANY CASES
TRANSITIONS HAVE OCCURRED- ONE
OF THE MAJOR. OBJECTIVES FOR
ORGANIZATION I'M SURE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE FIRE SUPPRESSION
TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE- TO THE
FACILITY THAT MAY HAVE UNIQUE
FLAMMABLE LIQUIDS. ON SITE- WE
DID RECEIVE A MOCK UP OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT LATE
YESTERDAY. AND WE DO. THINK
KNOWLEDGE THAT. WE JUST PROVIDE.
BUILDING FOR THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY. USERS OF THE SONG TO
COMPLY THERE WILL BE A NEED FOR
SOME INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGES AT
THE FACILITIES TO- TRANSITION
TO CHLORINE FREE FALL MANY
ADDITIONAL TIME BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENT- IS GREATLY-APPRECIATED- WAR BEING A RIGHT
NOW TO REVIEW LANGUAGE IN
DETAIL- OKAY ANSWER QUICKLY IT
TO. ANY CHANGE IN OUR CURRENT
POSITION BUT IN THE MEANTIME I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE. OUR
APPRECIATE CAN. OUR IS TO WORK
IN AND IT IN THE CHANGE AND FOR
THE WILLINGNESS UP ALL TO
ENGAGE IN WHAT I THINK IT'S
BEEN A VERY CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE SO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THESE
COMMENTS TODAY. THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD- MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN FORTY FOUR.
OKAY AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM
LINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ADAM READY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER. ONE A
LINE MY COMMENTS- WITNESS PARKS
AND MISTER SCHECK BIG WE MAKE
THE CHAIR A STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF ON WORKING
WITH THAT- THE AMENDMENTS ARE
OUT OR CAL CAME WE'RE MEMBER
REVIEW. AND SO AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE IT BUT AT THE TIME
YOU HAVE AN OPEN MIND THANK.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DAWN KEPT
KEY WITH MAKE YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA A BILL CURRENTLY
WITHIN OPPOSE THEM UP AMENDED
POSITION I WE WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS. MR SHAH. I
AUTHOR HAVE STAFF PROPONENTS OF.
YOU WITH OUR COALITION. I WE TO
CURRENTLY REVIEWING OTHER
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ADD TO FOLLOWING UP
WITH THE AUTHORED DOCTOR IF YOU
THINK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. OPEN PHONE
MODERATE. SO WE SEEM TO BE IN A
POSITION. WHERE AND I'D LIKE TO
HEAR FROM- THE OPPOSITION IF
YEAH I HAVE THIS CORRECT THAT
WE ARE MOVING TO THE PRODUCTIVE
DIRECTION IT LOOKS AS IF WE
COULD HAVE AN AGREEMENT. BUT WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT EXACT THE EXACT
LANGUAGE AND YOU HAVE TO REACH
OUT TO YOUR MEMBERS. OF YOUR
ASSOCIATION- IS THAT CORRECT
MISS PARKS AND MISTER SHASTA
DISCOUNT FOR. YET DOCTOR COURT
AND YES THAT IS CORRECT- ADMIT
YOUR SEPTIC- MENTIONED WE HAVE
YOU RECEIVED THE MOCK UP
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON AND THEY
WERE STILL CONFIRM MAIN AND THE
THAT POSITION OF OUR
ORGANIZATION WITH OUR MEMBERS
AND HOPE TO HAVE A FINAL
DETERMINATION AND- WHO IS. THAT
I WOULD BE IN AGREEMENT WITH-
THIS PARTIAL WORKING QUICKLY TO
GET IT GET AN ANSWER BUT- I
DEFINITELY JUST WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE OF THE PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE SO FAR. THANK YOU. MY
CHIEF JOSH TOOK HER IN MY
SCIENCE FELLOW- RACHEL SO VERNE
FOR- MEETING ALL OF THE-
MEETINGS AT THE STAKE HOLDERS
AND- SENATE ALLEN THE STAFF
RIGHT QUESTION. YES THIS WELL
OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO THE AUTHOR
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO OUR FIRST
FUNDERS AS WE HEARD FROM THE
WITNESS ABOUT THE PREVALENCE OF
CANCER ARE FIREFIGHTERS BUT
THIS IS ALSO AN ISSUE THAT CAME
UP AT AS A RESULT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES THE BILL. THAT WATER
TESTING FOR P. FAUCET MY
DISTRICT WE HAD TO SHUT DOWN
TWO WELLS AS A RESULT OF IF YOU
FIVE LEVELS AND IT'S VERY MUCH
BELIEVED. THAT THOSE LEVELS ARE
AS A RESULT OF. THIS EXACT
FIREFIGHTING FOAM AT A TRAINING
CENTER IN THE AREA OF THE WELLS
SO. AS OTHER WITNESS. ARE
FACING EXTREME COST TO CLEAN UP
THOSE P. FAST TO GET THAT WATER
SUPPLY BACK ONLINE CURRENTLY WE
HAVE A REDUCED WATER SUPPLY TO
MY CONSTITUENTS AS A RESULT OF
ALL THIS SO. I REALLY THE HARD
WORK YOU PUT IN YES AND I AM SO
GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE MOVING IN A
DIRECTION WHERE WE WILL. BE
CONTINUING TO CONTAMINATE THE-
PIES OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
REALLY HARD WORK OF BOTH OF TWO
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY THE SAMBAR GARCIA
WITH. EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX
NINE ALSO SO EVER MURATSUCHI.
RAN A BILL A FEW YEARS EARLIER
I REALLY NEED TO CAL EPA AND-
DONE. I CALLED SB SIXTEEN FORTY
NINE THAT THAT THAT HAD TO DO
WITH WITH THAT WITH EXPOSURE
AND- OVERSIGHT. ADDITIONAL
LATER. WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHERYL- SURROUND WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS-IF
FIVE. WOULD LOVE FOR YOU TO
ALLOW RATE A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO IT I
THINK EVERYBODY'S. VERY
APPRECIATIVE- EVERYBODY COME
TOGETHER YOUR HARD WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
COMMITTEES WORKERS WHILE. ON A
CALIFORNIA. ACTUALLY GETTING
SOMETIMES ACTUALLY GO OVER
THOSE AMENDMENTS. I'M A GIVE
YOU A GOOD. A FELLOW TODAY AND-
LOOK FOR TO SEEING THIS IN ITS
FULL FORM ON THE FLOOR. WE CAN
DO THAT IN YOUR COURT. THE
QUESTION. FOREVER YOU FOR WELL
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS- I
WILL LEAVE THIS COPY THE MOCK
UP FOR MY FRIEND- CENTER MATHIS
FOR HIM TO REVIEW BUT BUT- YOU
KNOW MIDDLE TIMIDLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO PHASE OUT THIS
DANGEROUS TOXIC IN CARCINOGENIC
CALL THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO
FIGHT FIRES A FEW THE THIRTY
THREE AND FIFTY. YOU KNOW IN
YOUR TO YOUR QUESTION IS A
MEMBER IT IS THAT WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO MAKE URE. THAT THERE
IS A REASONABLE PHASE IN TIME.
FOR AIRPORTS FIRST YOU KNOW-
FOR REFINERIES. OFFER FOR THOSE
TYPES OF SITUATIONS WHERE- WE
WERE THERE OBVIOUSLY NERVOUS
ABOUT WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
FIGHT FIRE THAT'S WELL TO ME
NUMBER ONE. MOST IMMEDIATE.
THIS THERE ARE OTHER AIRPORTS
REFINERS PARTS THE THAT HAVE
FOUND A WAY. TO DO THIS WITHOUT
P. FIVE AS A WE'RE GIVING THEM
OR GIVE THEM SOME TIME. WE'RE
GIVEN SOME FLEXIBILITY THE FIRE
MARSHAL BUT EFFECTIVELY WHERE
PHASING OUT THIS DENTIST.
CARCINOGEN AND- WITHOUT AYE AYE
ONCE AGAIN THANK THANK THE
STAFF A GREAT DEAL- FROM YOUR
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR AND I
RESPECT FOR US AND I HAVE A-
VERY GOOD. SO THE MACHINES DO
PASSED IN THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MISTER
SECRETARY GENERAL SB TEN FORTY
FOUR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK. QUIRK HI. A REGULAR
ARAMBULA I BAUER-KAHAN BACKING
AND HIGH FLORA FLOOR I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE MATHIS- AT THIS I.
CG MURATSUCHI AYE OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING AND RIGHT.
THANK YOU MAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MOTION PASSES MY FEAR OF
THE HAVE ONE MORE PRECIOUS CHIU
NEEDS TO ADD ON SAID. IS
SECRETARY THE CONSENT CAL S.
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX THE CURRENT
VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO MURATSUCHI
CG. PHONE CALL NEEDING. THANK
YOU. GOOD TO BE. CRISTINA.